if I'm applying for a job all right and
I say that job I failed that job I
failed that job I also failed how can I
say I did the job well when you also
jumped and well I think that we're
overlooking as well is no by no means
does any woman and can any woman predict
the outcome of their relationship right
or if the man's gonna stick around or if
I have a kid with this guy is he going
to stay with me he's going to marry me
but what women do do is we Overlook red
flags
it's not everybody but a lot of women
don't listen a lot of men don't listen
but if we're just talking about this for
a moment women make choices that they
know are not the right choices when they
know that it's not the right man
and women also leave for stupid reasons
okay so so okay okay reason number one
reason number one okay when you take
your marriage vows it's supposed to be
for Better or For Worse for sicknesses
and health not if I don't feel happy
today I I we fell out of love and I lost
myself what happened to For Better or
For Worse what happened
one of the number one indicators of
divorce is if a woman will start out
earning her man and she puts financial
gain above her kids that's a stupid
reason yeah thank you what kind of women
can we talk about the typical marriage
how many people are married
fifty percent of marriages I've been
divorced so half half well has anyone
married have you been married have you
been married have you been married
if we're talking now on the spectrum of
25 to 40. yeah mid-range age range then
obviously like we can talk about the
things of the woman has to do what she
does in the madness please just reopen
what you said because my ADHD is going
well which part which one oh I said
women divorce for stupid reasons right
so free reasons why do why do women okay
okay
when women are dating in their 20s and
30s right I can speak obviously for 20
years
um
you know the thing is you give people
chances
I'm not trying to find the perfect man
who does nothing wrong no because I do
okay well I feel yeah
guys
I want to dissect wait wait I wasn't
finished
on that side yeah don't want to leave
but then now you're saying why do women
leave right and the woman their reasons
are stupid for leaving yeah have you
heard about this thing called intuition
now potentially it could just be [__]
crazy sorry
it could be crazy but
at the end of the day like we know that
women have more connection to certain
things if they haven't been on
contraception for years and they haven't
been eating all the garbage that they've
been eating and drinking all the gin and
doing all of those things it
desensitizes the human connecting to the
Earth so I'm just saying intuition's a
real thing okay yeah but you know what I
mean but yeah that's like women feel
different intuition
so it's like I'll talk to a girl one
week and she hates her boyfriend and
then the next week she's in love with
her boyfriend
so I actually feel sorry for their
boyfriend because I'm like he probably
doesn't know whether he's coming or
going yeah
10 seconds I love him so much wait he's
done this I'm like this darling I'm
already tired I don't know about your
boyfriend but I'm tired I'm out and then
we'll go guys
those guys the guys that under intuition
it's like that's not what guys don't do
this guys I read something so
interesting the other day so basically
you know when women have this
contraceptive things on their arms yeah
apparently it changes your hormone so
imagine if you meet someone no [__] and
it's been found recently
um basically if you're on these pills
conceptive pills and you meet someone
and then you get married and all of a
sudden you go off of them and then a
patent the hormone Center you're not
attracted to your partner so that is a
lot of the things that's happening
around the world now yeah
I'm messing people's lives up they are
ruining girls and men thousands of
pounds
and whose fault is that who took it
women
[Music]
if it breaks and you don't know then you
know maybe sleep with people that you
want to have kids with but then yes
take him back to that point but super
sleep with people you might want to have
kids with but what but you remember you
said but then you've got to pick him to
make sure he's the one who's not going
to leave I mean you could you could
waste it you could you could wait
you could wait to get married before you
have a child
question
can I can I is it time to drop some red
pills into the sangria yeah go ahead yes
are we ready to spike yeah
let's go go ahead so the question was
does your potential partner or partner's
past matter yes
can I share my opinion on this all right
so
uh here let's let's let's do Let's do
let's do some uh let's do some lessons
in genetics and biology because we can
refer to our trusty friends uh from the
Gregor Mendel book of biology we
understand DNA do we not yeah yes if you
look in your family tree this is
statistically accurate you have twice as
many women in your family tree as you
have men you have twice as many women in
your family tree as men why what does
that mean
what does that mean women give birth and
there's more of them they're meant to
multiply yeah yeah what it means is that
a vast majority of women have babies
with the same men meaning what that
means the reason you have twice as many
women is a small percentage of men about
20 of men basically created all of us
Genghis Khan Genghis Khan has his DNA in
something like
180 million people today does that mean
he's been sleeping around bears in the
past life what it means let me explain
it it's a very simple thing where the
question was does a partner's past
matter what it says is very clear
what it says is very clear that women
continuously choose the men that other
women choose that's what it means we
know you know what we know this we know
the statistic from dating apps right 80
percent of men have absolutely no
prospects of sex or dating at all
because you can look at the Tinder data
80 of men get zero matches ever one
percent of men are like Genghis Khan
levels so there's a person's past matter
if you look at the science it clearly
matters that women want to choose men
that have had the most partners because
that's who they keep choosing all the
time wow so that might not be an
emotional argument that's just
statistics it's a fact
okay can I say that from the other side
how men look at this argument okay from
a men's perspective it's a little
different so I'm in the business of
effectively like our company LGBT we
sell high-end bespoke suits we go to
Executive offices so we meet rich men
all the time really what I do is I
recruit young men and women to sell to
very high net worth people okay and this
is a conversation for young men I'm
going to say this to the young guys out
there here's a question what is a man
really doing with his life to increase
his value we can measure it you know
what the number the answer is what does
a man measure in value what do we
measure
that's money it's just money right if
they so here's a question does a man
have any incentive to It is Well
influence effectively to transmit that
into money and by the way influence and
fame are very highly correlated to how
many sexual partners a man has access to
so you're saying the same thing I just
want the guy that every other woman
wants that's what you're saying but
you're not saying it okay so does a man
have any incentive to increase his value
through financial gain does a man have
that incentive yes okay do women want to
be wealthy too like you girls you're all
going to be 61 there and say I want to
retire do you want to have something to
retire with of course okay so here's
here's the here's a statistic the
typical retired married man
average but not typical average the
numbers of course there's a big gap but
the average married man retires with
about six hundred thousand US dollars in
savings 600 000 the average divorced
single man
this is the statistic retires with a
hundred thousand okay the average
divorced and remarried man retires about
400 000. so the outcome of staying and
getting married has a significant impact
on a man's value and status and
ultimately his comfort in life so the
question therefore is does the spouse
you choose matter yes why does it matter
yes we can actually measure with money
that it literally like we have a number
that we can look at and says yes the
spouse issues matters okay well a
psychologist will tell you there's two
ways to ruin your life number one become
an alcoholic number two marry an
alcoholic well here's a question what's
the problem with Marrying an alcoholic
ladies and gentlemen impulse control
impulse control how's that going to be
the fact that they're going to be
talking rubbish and no one will
understand this and they're gonna kids
and all sorts of craps so the question
is would you marry an alcoholic and say
no I won't why not because the chance of
divorce are much higher so does a
woman's past matter okay well let's say
a woman had a lot of sexual partners
does that indicate any sort of I don't
know it doesn't have any impact on her
pair bonding ability
yeah well we know that it does okay so
if I if you marry a hoe because that
let's just go right to the core here
that's the question answer the question
yeah so if you do that are your chances
of divorce higher well she's got lower
pair bonding she's got lower impulse
control she's not a strategic thinker
because she knows impulsively and
intuitively that she's reducing her
value so when I coach a young guy that
we hire into our company we don't just
look at their job we look at their life
plan and we want to be I have two more
stats real quick we want to be strategic
and we want to optimize for success and
mitigate for risk are you mitigating for
risk if you're not looking at a woman's
past you're creating yourself an
opportunity for failure by the way
here's a question guys what percentage
of millionaires are married
extreme or something I'm getting married
so I'm getting married
as well okay 85 so the question is let's
let's look into that like we're asking
again there's a partner's past matter
why is it that 80 minutes
you want you want that or you don't want
that if you don't want that I know it's
hard to hear you don't want to hear it's
just facts thank you no honestly it's
interesting to learn thank you so much
guys do you guys do you guys think that
for a man to become a millionaire he has
to be a strategic thinker yes do you
think no no no
what's going on so you think so you
think the statistically millionaires are
less strategic or equally
I think millionaires it depends on have
you born have you been born into wealth
time you've been given I was born into
the Soviet Union I grew up on food
stamps okay so um I guess yeah it
doesn't matter but some people some
millions
in like privileged families don't do
anything we're just looking at
statistics every rule has a rule breaker
and again mitigate for risk so it's like
if you want to bet all your money on you
know 20 black on the roulette and you're
like I'm gonna make a billion dollars
yeah some people made a million dollars
rolling that most people lose everything
they ever had it's bad risk mitigation
we're talking about statistics right so
it's like if the partner that you choose
matters to the outcome of your life you
have to be strategic about it so does it
matter well the numbers clear indicate
it matters
no you can be delusional you can say
well it shouldn't matter okay can so you
you make suits for a high net worth
clients can you tell me about the women
they pick as wives yeah so first of all
do they pick Alpha females when I no
absolutely not uh so so here let me tell
you guys I had my dinner last night with
my wife it was her 10th anniversary and
she said my wife said something really
profound right like it kind of shocked
me a little bit is I said you know it's
so much fun like building a life with
you I told her it's so much fun built we
got four kids I'm like it's so much fun
building a life with you because I've
had a great 10 years right and she goes
oh I didn't get in here to build I
wanted to write on this train oh that's
so sad that's what she said
she's gonna be rude because honest
though um
again well let's let's look at it like
the Simon London today I fly back on
Saturday I live in Estonia on Wednesday
I take off to Dubai on Saturday I'm in
moderate India the next the next
Wednesday I'm in New Delhi I am in
demand because I'm I'm a successful dude
and you know what all successful dudes
are in demand they're not sitting at
home smoking point they're doing they're
getting calls they're doing stuff and
you know what they're needed they're
needed because it's hard to find
competency good people yeah you know
what you're doing all these what where's
your wife and the kids at home actually
it's not true so I'll tell you right now
um uh earlier this year I took my whole
family where'd we go no no I mean I mean
just when you're working just now you
know the places we've got to go so in
between how much did you see what do you
quite often I bring my whole family on
my trips
are they homeschool no no they're going
to like an English college but like so
like the last year January we had a
video shoot in Hawaii I took my wife my
wife and four kids to Hawaii uh after
that we had a company trip to Croatia I
took my whole family with me no no so
I'm just saying so you know in the past
couple of days in the next few days that
you said all the places you're going to
so
it's your anniversary today well yeah
and so have you been with your wife
today yeah yeah so and then you're going
when you when's your next trip I come
back in three days back home and then
I'm home for three days and then I take
off for another week and a half okay
yeah because you know when you the way
you said it I was like okay so that's
what I was sort of wondering so that's
when you get so that's when you get to
see wife and the kids in that I see my
wife and kids all the time okay can you
tell me more about that like what traits
do men um in that position look for well
the thing the thing about it like I
don't want to over generalize but there
is definitely a trend so I'll tell you
guys this is a story I tell all the time
I've met a lot of dudes whose wife is
just not getting deed down or something
because she's like right like it's like
but here's the thing let me tell you
guys about I've worked with clients that
I work with clients for real that are
world class musicians and movie stars
that are household names that everybody
knows like right and I've been asked
this before on on uh somebody asked me
like is there any difference between
like the wife of this really famous
musician and this really famous movie
star to the wife of just a regular dude
like yes their wife's wives are the most
supportive the happiest like I'll
deliver a suit to some Average Joe and
his wife saying anything makes them look
fat I'm like no you don't like your
husband but when I deliver like for I
mean I remember I'll tell you guys an
Alice Cooper story like the musician his
wife like she came in and she's like you
look amazing he's 75 years old he's he's
old he's like you look amazing that's so
perfect like wow look at the energy that
she was just so and every single
extremely famous person I've been with
like that but was it real yes their
wives I mean there's a respect aspect to
it but like man well I'm thinking this
dude's 75 years old he's still torn by
the way it's like he doesn't have time
to come home and put up with like
weirdness you know what I mean and I
think she knows but she knows that
because that's why she would do it
because obviously he's going to keep it
moving and then obviously the money's
gonna stop uh I don't know the answer to
that I'm I'm sorry I was asked an
anecdotal experience like when I'm
dealing with
a successful
um ultimately they're very very busy
like they're you know these are like
almost all successful men are a type men
like they're up in the morning they're
working their butts off like when you
think about this is a really interesting
point that I've noticed by the way you
can cut me off at any time
um you would think like oh he's rich but
he has to be unhappy or he's he's got
this great job but he should but he's
just like unfit no success goes with
success like the best looking people are
the ones that make the most money
everything goes together so these guys
like they're the ones in the gym in the
morning they look amazing they're so
sharp and you know I've I've gone down
the street with some of my clients like
hey let's grab a coffee whatever and I'm
walking down the street and I see the
women's eyes just gravitate towards
these guys because a woman knows when
she sees a high value man and by the way
we just established that women
continuously choose men that other women
pick we know this genetically right and
so I you know if a guy like that is well
first of all is he more strategic in
picking his wife yes everything in his
life has planned out your dad Pearl's
like a really successful guy I'm sure
he's really strategic in the way he
makes decisions is he not yeah he's very
strategic and I'm sure you saw a lot of
that growing up like he would just be
like okay pro and con let's go
um yeah every time every time I cry
about a business problem I call my dad
and he fixes it for me
it's not a life problems
anything that goes wrong
yeah
I didn't fix it because daddy that's
what that is that's what daddies do
therefore
that's what I mean men don't want to
deal with Alpha females though because
like the men like that like I'm thinking
of I think I'm thinking wait I'm
thinking of my dad right and he he is so
logical he is so logical that like and
and me when I when I have a business
problem or whatever I get so stressed
out sometimes I'll like cry like I'll
just be like and I'll call him and he's
so good at just like okay what is the
problem
what is the problem this is like okay
here's one solution here's two solutions
but like men like that they don't want
to have a girl that's constantly arguing
with them
that might not be what you meant but
typically that's what all alcohol
because what is it what is an alpha
that's a leader yeah so so how how is in
that situation I mean that's that's like
family but in that situation
always pig-headed leaders you don't know
me that it's my way of the highway uh
yeah but at the end of the day like they
want to know that you trust them to make
a decision so they don't want they don't
want to hear like why like one thing I
didn't understand about men is like when
you say why to them it's like annoying
it is like they're like why is he doing
this
you know when you do that why why
because I [__] said so yeah yeah that
one not every two seconds why sometimes
but sometimes though it's when they ask
why sometimes it's all because well but
when the wires keep coming and the wires
keep coming it's because I said so in it
yeah but that's the point so that's why
because what is an alpha that's a leader
so the leader is the one that that's
saying this is where we should go this
is the problem yeah and so when I when I
speak to my dad like I have a really
good relationship with him because I
trust him yeah and because when he tells
me to do something for them I mean
sometimes sometimes I don't but for the
most part like I listen right but there
you go and sometimes but then that's
what I mean yeah but usually when I
don't listen it doesn't work out and I'm
like I said yeah but we know that that
that's what happens but then it doesn't
I think I think it sometimes it's just a
perception that's I think that's maybe
another thing that's maybe another topic
the perception of an alpha on an alpha
and an alpha female and an alpha male
yeah I think that might be I think
there's different perceptions
but the question is why why do we have
those perceptions like we can't if if
the women that say I am an alpha female
have a reputation of something like
that's the alpha female's fault
like there's a reason they have that
reputation why is it going to be a fault
to be in an alpha female I mean I just
feel like everything in life is your own
fault so if you're if if they make an
assumption because you're an alpha
you're not going to be your own
greatness instead of you I'm full why
does he have to be well
in this situation it's because men don't
want it definitely because
I mean I don't know your personal
situation but typically the most
successful men with the most options
don't typically want Alpha females as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible